all right if you like to take naps yes
come up to my office in the middle of
the day you know what I'm doing because
there's a new study that says they may
be good for our hearts research
published in the journal heart found
that adults who took one or two daytime
naps a week had a 48 percent lower risk
of cardiovascular problems than non
Nappers the length of the nap though did
not influence the fine thanks a lot of
companies though actually have nap rooms
which i think is a good idea I can't
help but think though you're gonna judge
if you say to the boss you know I'm
gonna take a nap right now in the middle
of day but companies are putting in nap
rooms for their boys if you hear story
from my office it's a good thing napping
is natural before industrialization we
didn't used to sleep an eight-hour
chunks reduces sleeping chunks all
throughout the day right this is true
why get rid of the napping that we got
so used to when we were in day care
companies actually do promote napping in
other countries in China in Spain you
have this yes lady both so that idea and
now you see it's good for your health
that's right good